spring 2021 is coming to a wrap and with
it
a lot of huge names are reaching their
end or in some cases
just the midway point and by most
standards on my anime list
seasonal anime above 8 stars are
considered to be part of the best of the
best batch
to your eternity tokyo avengers fruits
basket
there's a lot of good anime this season
but
what was absolutely criminal this season
is how
underrated odd taxi my personal favorite
show of the season
ranked among these anime clocking in
at the 26th most popular anime this
season even behind
absolute mid shows like full dive and
eden zero despite its high score overall
it's still insanely underrated as an
original mystery anime yo hold on is
that wait wait
are all the characters animals well yeah
but oh my god you furry
ew bro zootopia looking fur
[Music]
certain perceptions i'd say of anime
like b stars with animal casts have
kind of tarnished their reputation as a
whole even though i hear the b-stars
manga is actually great
but i must say do not sleep on odd taxi
odd taxi is an original mystery anime
out this season 13 episodes and it's
truly a diamond in the rough
not just in the spring 2021 season alone
but among all anime in general in my
opinion
it is so incredibly interesting with
such a fresh take on storytelling
akin to anime like baccano if you're
familiar
the story follows the rather eccentric
walrus orokawa your
everyday taxi driver really but it is
through this taxi
this physical and metaphorical vehicle
that drives the show forward and we get
intertwined in this vast web of
characters and storylines that are
so beautifully dynamic in their own ways
kabusawa a hippo who will do anything to
get famous
yamamoto a fox and manager of an idol
group that is
embroiled in an underground scheme
tanaka
an eraser collector turned gotcha game
addict turned
villain andyano my personal favorite
a scooter riding porcupine and gangster
who only talks in rhyme
seriously guys check this out
one
[Music]
these parts really reminded me of like
the rap versus they had in devilman
crybaby if you're familiar
and it's just so much fun this hip-hop
beat
cues every single time he talks and he
rides it
every time and that's not to mention
just how well the soundtrack fits
every other part of the show it's not
just these moments specifically
i feel like recently with record of
ragnarok i've been writing a bit of an
ost
appreciation wave and odd taxi has a
great one
especially the opening it is this
beautiful jrnb
track that always starts every episode
off with the right mood
i'll get copyrighted probably if i play
it so just look it up on your own time
but
it's great it's awesome the soundtrack
works perfectly with the mysterious
moments and the exciting ones it just
it's beautiful anyway back to the plot
as i said earlier the format of
storytelling is very similar to baccano
if you've watched it
if you haven't it essentially means we
follow multiple characters on their own
independent stories that all eventually
intertwine
in one way or another it's always a bit
confusing at first because there's so
many things going on at once
but it makes it perfect for mystery
stories
you slowly unravel pieces of each
person's story and it's just so
satisfying once they finally come
together
and what is great about how odd taxi
does it is how all of the pieces connect
to
odokawa our main character he is the
central piece somehow despite him being
probably one of the least charismatic
orokawa is
difficult to describe he's extremely
blunt and straight to the point he's
kind of a mood killer
and in a story that is so clouded in
mystery and deceit
and gangsters trying to get their own
way he does stand out still as
a great protagonist somehow through his
taxi he becomes involved in the case of
a missing girl that the police have been
tracking
and this unfortunately through reasons i
won't spoil
attracts the attention of yakuza and
corrupt cops
and somehow an idol group too
i don't know and in a way i think that
making all of the characters animals
really did serve an important purpose in
the show besides just a stylistic
decision
it doesn't just give each person a
distinct look but
it furthers the sense of variety within
the show
as i was saying earlier we've got idols
and fans of idols and
comedians trying to make it big and
brazilian street fighter
doctors and by making them all these
different animals it contributes to the
almost absurdity of the anime and the
individualistic character of all of them
but when i said absurd it's not to say
the show is unrealistic really no one
has
outrageous strengths or powers or
anything like that the
absurdity lies in the stories and the
coincidences or
events that bring all of these very
different characters together
for example the show starts off with
this hippo kabusawa getting into
otakawa's taxi
he takes a selfie with otakawa in
another feudal attempt to go viral on
twitter
but then he actually does because he
accidentally captures dobu in the
background of the photo who
is a notorious criminal and then dobu
comes to threaten odokawa but it's not
even because of that photo but because
otokawa gave a ride to the missing girl
in the past
who for some reason is now being tracked
by gangsters
every storyline somehow connects to one
another and makes a new mystery in the
process and it's all just very
very well done
[Music]
the show is very much a slow burner i'd
say only halfway or maybe three quarters
through the show do you
really finally have a full grasp on the
entire situation
involving otokawa and his taxi but
that's not to say that it's
ever boring because the characters
really drive this show forward and keep
it constantly interesting
the first half of the show basically
just consists of like short skits
following each other
most of them taking place in otokawa's
taxi it lets you not just get to know
the cast but sometimes even gives like
important insights into life despite
coming from an
animal's mouth if you like the
monogatari series for example
that really dialogue intensive and
expressive aspect of it
then the first half of this series will
really hit home for you i'm sure
as it did with me and the second half
collects everything you've learned the
interconnections between all these
characters and really turns it into an
overarching plot that you can follow
i really liked odd taxi because this
kind of mystery
one that doesn't depend heavily on say
action or fighting
and is pretty solely devoted to just
unraveling questions and an intriguing
story
isn't something i see often in anime or
at least
not as often as i would like to see it
even shows like baccano have a lot of
action
and fantasy elements stacked on top of
it but odd taxi is
really just an eccentric unique and
character-driven mystery that really
drew me in
and didn't let go until i caught up
this series is way too underrated for
how good it is
and i'm glad at the very least that its
overall rating is still high despite the
smaller fanbase
if you haven't checked it out yet i
highly recommend it as its last episode
airs next week
i'm very excited to see how all of these
different stories and questions get
answered
and i'm confident that it will cement
the top spot for me personally this
season
despite just how strong spring 2021 was
what do you guys think of it if you've
seen it if you haven't thoughts
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga and character
analyses
you